hello hello everybody
uh welcome to the stream i'm uh
grandmaster mircha pearly grass
and today's
topic is uh missed opportunities
in the endgame
so as you well known after a long game
there comes the
the end game and in the past it was
possible to adjourn nowadays
is not possible to adjourn but
nevertheless players were
either way players were getting tired in
the end game
and many mistakes uh could occur
and uh we will talk about that uh
i will show you games where the where
the opponents uh
agreed upon a draw but one of them was
winning
or one of the players resigned but
the position was actually a draw but
also mistakes
that
[Music]
simply appeared on the board
in the end game so
hello hello chess king
so we will start with
[Music]
with a nice example i would say a game
between
patrols vladimir and
none other than paul kerris played in
the munich olympiad
1936 hello hello everybody
how are you doing okay
and uh we start from uh
from this position it was uh
the ending occurred
much much earlier but
we talked about this this position
hello hello there and uh
white white is to move here so we have
white has the pair of bishops
and the past pawn on h5
on the other hand the black is upon up
this knight is a somehow misplaced
the knight should be closer to white's
king
white's uh h pawn and then black would
have no problems
okay obviously it's white to move and
let's see what
uh what happened in the game
um well i i also wanted to mention that
there
[Music]
there is not much material left
left on the board and so the chances for
a drawer
are are quite high because of that
yes steve nurse you you can improve you
just watch this these lessons and you're
going to improve for sure
um at the very least you will
you'll not you'll avoid mistakes uh
made in these games
bishop f1 bishop h3 um
you want to take on f5 yes taking on f5
is
obviously white uh wants to to go for
the f5 pawn
but bishop f1 bishop h3 is
is too slow white therefore white went
bishop
uh bishop d7
why why go the other way when
you can go directly to d7 and attack
your five pawn
and here black was had a choice
obviously king f6
uh fails to bishop b2
so in the game black played bishop e6 in
order to
save the f5 pawn if he goes b5 for
example just to ignore the
just to ignore that pawn there could
happen bishop bishop takes pawn
king g7 h6 was a threat
king g7 now this is possible because if
bishop b2 there is b
b4 you see b5 was important nevertheless
after bishop c5 the
the threat is bishop d4 check
black black is in trouble because now
it's equal material but
the white bishops are dominating this
knight is still misplaced
so this was a difficult position for
black
that's why black decides to
to keep the pawn on f5 to to defend the
pawn
and now okay the the exchange is uh
pretty much forced
and how do we continue now
[Music]
what do you think
h6 yes h6 um
obviously the only move otherwise uh
uh well if not yes very good very good
h6 um
if not for h6 then black is in time to
uh to to catch the h pawn and then
black even has an advantage and is
probably winning
probably yeah black is winning if not if
not for h6
so bishop b2 bishop e2 is not good
uh because of 95 and then the knight
knight is able to
to catch the pawn for example h6 there
could follow
something like knight f6 and you see
there is no
now h7 or bishop f6 there is
king takes and otherwise black just can
can just go king f7 king g6 then take
the pawn
and so on
uh well king of king f2 is just knight
g4 knight h6 so
losing the pawn at once
okay but h6 i mean this is some kind of
uh
fourth uh uh
fourth sequence king f7 what
what else and now black is going to lose
this knight
as i said before this knight is uh
slightly misplaced here
it was slightly misplaced in the
beginning
so it's all about timing here
obviously now if the knight moves then
pawn
promotes so black is forced to
give up the knight but it's okay because
he has
two pawns and the king is quite active
okay take take
uh if you gave me six hours i could find
that
no no no you need to find that in
in 30 seconds
so white went king f2
king h5 king g3
uh b5 and here
well i don't know probably they it was
they were able to adjourn
or something but maybe not at this point
because here
um the players agreed upon a draw
so what do you think is that a fair
result
or did we miss something before
or here
um white is winning
but how
what what is uh what is the plan so
yes yes i think i think it's good to
to let you calculate a little bit
i mean i don't i don't want to jump to
the to the conclusions these were strong
players
uh okay
it's not only it's a
it's not only the first move it's it's a
plan maybe or
what do you want to do here
we take on f5 and run but how do we take
on f5
yes how can white make progress yes good
question steve north
very good
yeah for example if bishop b4 there is
king g6
and now what
king h4 king h6
bishop will go to f8 well
maybe for example now bishop c5 king
g6 bishop f8 if you want like this not
to allow me to go to
h6 but i can go king f7 attack the
bishop and then the king
may go back to g6 so
he's not really
disturbed by this by this line
so we need a plan here
king f6 is not safe for black well king
f6 maybe white could uh
could get with the king into to h5
and then go for the f5 pawn
like here king
well we need to calculate this but maybe
king h5 is possible
i'm not sure because black could also
start rolling his pawns so
one needs to calculate this
so we need to we need to
to get a plan okay bishop before king g6
are reasonable most let's say
um king f2 yeah
yes we could try we could try to get the
king to the other side
so let's say king f2
black rose both pawns well
i i just wanted to prove that bishop f8
was going nowhere but
i didn't want to calculate if black can
roll both pawns but
probably that that is also possible uh
but yeah if if i calculate that line and
i see that black has king f7 i'll just
stop there so
i wouldn't i wouldn't even investigate
it further but indeed maybe king f6
also could work with k6 king d5 but
uh we need to we need to calculate that
okay so king f2 there could be king h5
now black is going for the f4 pawn
and
yeah so what do you think was
was the draw a good result or not
okay king is free kg4 this these are
obvious moves
bishop d6 and the
and the king goes to e5 well if bishop
d6 and king to e5 we shouldn't forget
about the e pawn so the
pawn is going um
yeah it turns out yeah bishop d2 maybe
bishop d2 king g3
[Music]
we should be one when now or before
yes we could play bishop e1 here
and put black into tom's one
black is going forward king h3
yes yes and you are right chest king and
we we can't talk zone theme so
white could go here king d4
hello there um and if king g2
king e5
and as you can see the bishop is
controlling both both pawns and
f5 pawn is falling king f1 bishop
a5 for example
kingi king e2 going for
[Music]
going to c4 and then playing b4 but then
king f5
and
white just win and
if uh in this position we are talking
about so if
we saw king g2 but if king g4
just back then there was a
king e5 so it was essential for the king
to
reach e5
yes that's the position with kg4 uh
if the king moves then uh f5 pawn is
falling
so e3 and then again bishop a5
just uh going forward two swank e2
bishop d2 and now black
black has to move the king
so king king f3 king f5
king f2
king four yeah
yeah exactly this is the line uh
queen take take
and
king d4 king d2
f5 v4 king c4
and the pawn race is just lost for black
hello hello so
white was uh
[Music]
easily winning with this uh subscribe
maneuver
it could be reached also in other cases
for example here
bishop p1 is the easiest but um
it also works like this for example
bishop d2
king g3 and now
bishop
[Music]
bishop c3 and if uh king g4 then again
we can go back bishop e1
well in the game uh in the game they
they just made a draw and i wanted to
point out that here
instead of b5
because you could say but maybe he can
win some tempi with b5 or
without b5 but then king g6 for example
just
uh the same king f2
king h5 king is three king g4
and now we have bishop d2 and again
follow
oh sorry followed by uh
[Music]
king d4 king e5 and winning
yeah well i mean for their level that's
uh that's an easy win and especially
since black uh
didn't really have uh any counterplay i
mean he couldn't he couldn't do anything
so that was the the first example for
today
missed opportunities in the end end game
as you saw uh
white uh why took a draw when by
uh by just playing on
and finding that the zhong's wrong idea
uh
he could have he could have won the game
so now let's move on to the next example
it's a more recent one it's from a game
leader in supanova versus chava vallo
played in heavies
2008.
now steve north there was no way for
black to hold in that
in the previous example
okay so we have a
crazy position here i'd say with the
material imbalance
black black is an exchange down but
he has one pawn for it and the
b4 and c3 pawns uh look very dangerous
however the the knight on b3 is blocking
the pawns
um and is doing
uh uh great job in
blocking the pawns and it's not obvious
how
how these pawns could uh could advance
so let's see what
what happened in the game just a little
bit
uh black was the move he played f6
trying to
open up the position
f4 well i i only looked at this
end game briefly it looks like a very
very interesting
endgame and
i couldn't really say what's what's
going on here
it's just uh very complicated king of
seven logical move
um well maybe it was interesting for
white to go rk2
trying to go to a7 who knows
but he goes through rook f2 well it was
important to move the rook because white
uh
otherwise white couldn't go to king f3
so king g6
now black played very logically here he
he is just activating the king
93 knight b6 knight c4
and gets nice in well
he could he could try that but it's not
so
it's not so easy and still it's uh yes
yes i know
but still is not clear how to how to
push these pawns
so this is a good thing in in an ending
to to just activate the king it makes
perfect sense
actually both players are trying to do
this
they are very expensive experienced
players
uh g4 white is limiting the black king
and also
uh pushing uh the pawns on the king side
where he
he has an extra h pawn
now black takes there obviously we can
only take
with the f pawn because we don't want to
allow an extra upon on the on the queen
side
so knight fb6
yeah as uh as you are saying black is uh
activating the
the knights the least active knight so
there we go knight
jumps to c4
[Music]
hello hello there so white is also
bringing the king into play
king goes to e4 towards the center where
it where it can look at both
[Music]
both lengths also try to keep an eye on
the pawn
but also maybe looking at the
king side
so once the knights are active black is
pushing with the king
maybe it was interesting to just go
kimchi sleep back
but white goes king e4
okay soon enough we'll we'll get to
we'll get to the point you'll see
black girls king h4
complete uh complete
activity of the king king to d3
going for the knight knight b2 king e4
well here he they could
i guess they could just repeat the most
with knight c4
uh not so not easy at all to
reach to bring the knight to 25 i mean
he had a knight on c4 but he needs this
knight from d5 to reach
a 5 which is i don't
i don't really see a way for it
okay here it was good for black to go
king g3 and rook f3
king g2 well with the
with an unclear position maybe rook fade
but
black is black is pushing a little bit
and black also didn't want to to repeat
the moves
uh however he played g5 just to stop
white's pawns and here
here a draw was was agreed between the
players
and uh yeah on good account because it's
uh it's just a crazy position who knows
what's going on
so now here comes my question to you
what do you think about this
did any of the players miss any
opportunity here
and i will let you think a little bit
about this
even black could be better yes
yes i mean it it was something crazy
so what do you think about the final
position
if black played knight a4 then e5
uh how to play uh maybe c5 you mean
but is not working
ok let's make it easier for you what do
you think about the final position
was black writing offering a draw or not
it would be a draw even if there is some
crazy idea
yeah probably they were in time trouble
and they also didn't
didn't know what was going on here i
mean with the last move black is
threatening maybe you want to go knight
f4 and then
take this h3 pawn so
this is this is indeed an amazing
position
black is the one pushing you could have
played on okay
okay i need more opinions
about this
rook f6 okay we've got some ideas now
white could exchange suck yes
yes okay
so it seems that black was uh
well the position was very unclear
probably black was pushing but
this final move g5 was
black was winning yes okay it wasn't
it wasn't easy it was maybe unclear
position i would say
knight f4 looks scary yes but as you can
see
the final move i'm going to give you a
hint now guys
so the final move g5 was uh was a
blunder
believe it or not it was just a blunder
and now it turns out that white was
winning
in this position
so it all starts uh like somebody
like chess king was saying
it all starts with the rook f6
well i didn't i didn't want to show you
this game uh
just this position and then i wanted to
to give you the flavor of this game like
show you a few more
moves before how to fight
so that you get into the spirit of the
fight okay so
rook f6 was
white's best chance and probably only
move
obviously going for the
uh for the e6 pawn well obviously if
knight f6 knight f6
is out of question because pawn takes
and then
there is the
there is no way to
[Music]
to catch that i mean we will see
knight f6 was actually the main move
knight f6 was the main move okay uh
just saying if king takes to h3 somebody
said king of three but
um rookie 6 is just winning because now
the e4
the the e pawn is uh is going to
be decisive also rook c6 is a is a scrap
okay so black has to take on f6
pawn takes what to do and now there is
only one way to
catch that pawn by playing knight c4 the
idea is
f7 there is 96 and the pawn is gone
so
not an easy position to to assess
however white has a
nice
[Music]
nice reply here nice a
nice solution let's see
what do you think
so yeah the pawn is running but not
quite the knight is there
any suggestions
well no suggestions it seems maybe
f7 then kinky three well f7
just uh losing the pawn
knight a5 i mean we shouldn't forget
that black can also
push this this guy
d5 oh d5 is a crazy move but
he just takes he can just take
the pawn and then what
knight a5 uh f7 ah 96 kinky five well
it's
not doing anything really king d3
um yeah f796
cat catches the pawn
guys we need to we need to look in the
other direction you are all looking to
the queen side
you see this these two connected past
pawns that are going to
do something look at this king
if only
no okay but look at the uh look at the
black king
yes we have the idea to make the
the black king actually not the white
one
yeah f7 96
[Music]
is with chuck yes very good andrew very
good so white has this resource here to
play
king f3 first so we don't we don't give
the f for
uh the f pawn so quickly
so easily i know you like to sacrifice
but this is
like one of the one of white's main
assets this pawn so we can go king f3
and now you see the
there is a threat to play f7 and f8
queen
and so the only way to the
only way to stop it is to go 96
and now white can go king g2
[Music]
and the black king is stuck here
and if only the white knight could reach
somehow
f3 well then there is a checkmate
because the black knight cannot defend
both
uh this threat and the f4 uh and f
pawn so let's say black goes knight f7
the idea would be to go e5 and
open up the position and now how do we
bring the knight to f3
and chuck made the black king
black also has the c pawn so i think we
should hurry with that knight because
black has a
black would have ideas yes very good
d5 very good very good chess king so d5
is
i mean white has several ways but d5 is
the most beautiful
uh i will show d5 just in a moment but
also knight c1 for example
is winning and then c2
92 and the knight is heading towards g1
um if knight h6 is just f7 and
followed by knight g1 so b3 knight g1
and knight f3 checkmate
but as as i said d5 is the most
beautiful move
because it frees up the d4 square and
then the knight can go to
to f3 so black cannot
really allow this pawn because then the
knight will not be able to stop
both pawns so he has to go
he has to take the pawn
yeah at least you're a queen up
exactly and now knight goes to d4 and
there is this threat
threat of knight s3 95
i could almost call this a study but
yeah it happened in the real game
95 and now how do we continue
f7 of course f7
well if knight f7 then just checkmate
uh c2 we put a queen there
very good f7 yes yes guys c1 queen
and we have a checkmate
so indeed i i agree this looks more like
a study
and it could only happen by chance uh
why not look well maybe if rook then
knight g6 or something
96 knight f4 so
maybe rook was possible as well
yeah rook was probably winning but
let's let's put a queen there it's safer
so as i said i don't know how the
position was before
but after black last move g5 why it was
definitely winning
but um
it was not it was not easy to realize
that and
uh i also don't know how much time on
the clock
the players had so
promoted night uh yeah
promoting tonight probably is very nice
and you're right yeah
yeah yeah promote promoting tonight is
is indeed nice i i didn't i didn't think
about that but yeah
you're right
okay so
cruel yes this is better yeah this this
looks fine we could have changed knight
f3 and then to have knight g6 checkmate
but yeah this is for
this is more beautiful you're right guys
you're right
so this was uh i guess this was a nice
example so let's move on to to the next
one
probably by now an already well-known
game
hilar person versus rugger played in
political cup 2015
well this this one is quite well known
uh there was no time for c5 there
white the knight was just checkmating
so we have this we have this ending it's
uh
well then uh he would lose
there was d take c6 and the pawns were
unstoppable
so we have descending um
black's position is slightly more
preferable
because there are pawns on both sides
and he has the bishop versus the knight
but there are not so many
pieces left on the board not so many
pawns and
perhaps white can uh
i mean objectively white should hold
this ending
in the game white played king d2
also there was a he could go for example
g3
d4 king d2 but he preferred to go
king d2 immediately
um idea is to go there
black goes king f4
and
the king is going to g3 g2 take the
actual pawn
so white has to go 92
and now yeah we get into this
king and pawn ending
that that we need to assess correctly so
i will just show you how
[Music]
how the game went on black played b5 in
order to gain space on the
on the queen side
white played b4 since
king g1 was quite hopeless after a5
so he had to go a b4
but then black is just uh
playing f5 and is uh
with the exchanges to follow he he's
going to
to make room for the king to go to the
queen side you will see
king g1 g4 takes and now he
he takes for the king if he takes for
the pawn then just king f1
so he takes with the king and the idea
is to go
uh king f4 king f2
f4 and white resigned here because
after he moves the king there follows
king
3 followed by f3 they change the pawns
and the king is
king has a freeway to go to the queen
side and
collect the pawns so
white resigned and now my question is
what do you think about this
what do you think about this ending was
this the logical outcome
for this game
yeah this is this is famous
yeah this is famous but this is nice i
mean
indeed a drone
but why yes we there is the a4 idea
he did
[Music]
okay so let me let me ask the question
some other way here
okay so indeed there is uh the position
is a draw
so white resigned when the position was
actually a draw
but both players uh
both players believe that
black was winning so even
[Music]
the player would black was not um
was expecting white to white to resign
he was expecting to
to win the game so they both missed this
idea
and uh here actually out of
three kings out of four kings king moves
only one of them is losing
and the other three are are drawn
and of course resigning is also losing
as it did in the game
so the only uh
the trick in this in this position
is that when black goes king g3 black
white should have while should move king
to f1 uh
so as afterwards after f3 he can
he can go faster to to the queen side so
that's why the only move that
loses here uh the only king move the
pawn moves loose
of course is king f1
and then after king g3 king g1 there is
f3 and the white king is uh
[Music]
is losing a tempo so the the king has to
be on f1
however if white just makes a
natural move like king g1 or
k2 k1 are all the same
then just f3 um
king king f1 king g3
take take king one king is three
well king d1 king is three doesn't
really matter
now white could also go could even go
king c1 king c3 if he wants to but
at some point he has to do it and now is
the time to
to go for the a4 move
which is a very important resource
and
[Music]
obviously black takes on a4 then
there are two double bonds on the
a500 and so there is no
no wind there and if black goes king c3
then
[Music]
white can exchange the pawns and uh uh
gets the king to c1 just in time
so this is very important when black
takes uh
the b for pawn he has king b2
and is getting the opposition and
the position is just a draw
but yeah this was this was a
well-known example but
it can it can happen in a game
especially
after after a long game you're tired and
you can easily miss
me such details
all right let's move on to
to the next one
a less known example
here have the game yuri averbach
versus what kites
played in um
russian championship soviet union
championship in 1969
so black is an exchange up
and
[Music]
exchange for a pawn but there is this
h h4 pawn which is dangerous
white has two ways to go here there is
bishop f5 in order to
defend the pawn or e5 as we
was well known in the ending it's good
to exchange
um
pawns if you are if you are worse so
just exchanging the pawns and hoping
that
that game is is a draw
so what would you do here
we should be five and hope hope for the
best i would say
resign well not yet
the designing is not the solution you
are bishop h7
okay we'll come back to it welcome back
to it guys
in the game i decided to exchange some
pawns
it says drone yes yes exactly
[Music]
so
it took two king takes
bishop e6 and here the position was
[Music]
here the players
agreed upon a draw so yeah it says draw
and it happened to be a draw
what do you think is this right or was
it the other way right
bishop f5 or disadding
well probably black didn't find any way
to black seems to be winning
black wins
rookie 2 maybe it's too
too rushed because white could go for
the pawn
he should not have played h4 uh well
the pawn was on h4
the pawn was on h4 too late for that
but those position with the pawn where
the pawn had to be on h5 and not on h4
are with the when the
the bishop is on the dark square is
when it's a dark square bishop so in the
in
those endings it's important to have the
ball on h5
in order to win so if white had a
dark square bishop then indeed with a
pawn on h4 it would be a draw at the
pawn on h5 it would be a win
[Music]
we have that that's well known positions
but
well known position but this is not the
case here because
we have the lights light square vision
so i did maybe maybe in the game uh
black also thought it was something like
that
that that the opponent is on h4 and
uh das is a is a fortress
but yeah yeah it looked like a blockade
but
black was black was actually winning
in the position where they they made a
draw
so it could follow here
king
black black will have to go for
checkmate ideas okay it makes sense to
bring the king first to
to f4 to bring the king closer to the
pawns
and now white plays king h2 just
just waiting that follows
check on it too well if
if he goes to the first rank it's
totally hopeless because king
reaches g3 and then h3 and
it's just over so king h3 is the only
move
king g5 defending the pawn
what does my shirt say it says
london is
is in our genes
okay so king g5
and now white goes let's say
bishop c8
yeah and here
black has a
[Music]
black has a winning idea it's uh
to play rook b2
and then bishop d7
well there is there is a point here
when
[Music]
when white goes rook bishop e6 black
wants to go
rogue d2 and then um so you'll see
bishop d7
he goes rook c2 now
um bishop e6 white needs to keep this
bishop on this diagonal because
otherwise there is check and
followed by king g4 and winning and now
there is
rook d2
and this is a two song the bishop cannot
continue to
move on that diagonal and now bishop f7
rook d3 king h2
and of course there is no time for kg4
because of bishop e6 back
and but here there is h3
king f41
okay uh let me just finish this so h3
bishop is three bishop e6 then king h4
followed by room t2 king g3
is completely over but king king f4 when
uh
just king there is no there is no need
for this because
as you can see when
when we reach this 2x position
white bishop has to
has to leave the h3 c8 diagonal
and the bishop goes f7 then there is
check and
h3 and then k4 and completely winning
so uh
probably pod guides uh took the draw
because
[Music]
he thought averbach was an expert in the
ending and
he was but white's position was just
losing
and now back to back to the starting
position
as you said bishop bishop f5 was the
was the good move and bishop f5 actually
makes a draw so
white uh
quite hard to play e5 so and both
players uh
uh miss the point of of descending
and here okay let's see what could
happen rook g3 check
[Music]
king f2 only only move if king reached 2
there is rook
rook f3 and the pawn falls so king
f2 and now rook d3
and what then what
[Music]
what would you do here
black is trying to
to break up the blockade somehow
and we need a good move here
well um
i don't think the i don't think the king
should go closer to the rook
because the king should be closer to the
h
to the h pawn if we just go hunting the
rook
this pawn is going to the spawn is going
to queen
and e5 loses to king f5
and
very good very good bishop bishop e6 is
the move
well there was a trap here there was a
trap if king g2
uh maybe bishop
[Music]
maybe bishop h7 works as well
uh but if king g2 black had a trap that
was this rook d5
it's okay i wanted to show it anyway
pawn takes c5
king f5 it's very nice that's why
i wanted to show you the to show it king
of three
h3 and uh
and the pawn ending is
[Music]
his loss of king h3 king
[Music]
f4 king g2 kg4
and white is white is not in time to
to jump to d3 and make a draw
the king can only move one square
that's why
white had to take this into account and
logical move is to play bishop
bishop e6
and the position is a draw now h3
seems to be like the only try otherwise
of course white would uh
go back to the with the king to g2
so h3 is the is the try
and now we should
we should take care of that pawn
immediately and we go
king g1
um great idea to go
k2 and then take the pawn we can always
exchange the
pawns on e5 with e5 check
and rookie 3 and
[Music]
now is the right moment to
play e5 finally
just get rid of the pawns pawn takes
pawn takes
king takes king h2
king f4 and it turns out that white can
take the h3 pawn
check and uh
this is a draw because white can
[Music]
so let me say it without a d4 point this
d5 point this would be lost
but because of the d-pawn white can
white can use a d-pawn to
to distract the rook and
get with the king out of out of the
corner
so d6 rook d2
d7 well cannot really take it
king h4 and there we go king g1
the king is running away the losing
position would have been
with if black manages to bring the king
to g3
take this pawn and somehow bring the
rook to f2
with the with the king in the corner
white would lose but now the king can
now the king is just running away
[Music]
so there is no way for this grip to to
happen
because uh because of the d7 point black
cannot
take the bishop so this this is just a
drawdown
the king is running away
[Music]
okay so
this uh this is all for today i
i hope i found some interesting examples
with missing opportunities in india in
the endgame
and positions where the players
took a draw or resigned but
they they could have hoped for more
so yeah i hope my my examples were
entertaining
thank you thank you so much for watching
and
see you next time bye